you come to this party a lot why is this
important for you to be at year because
Elton's extraordinary and what he's
doing in the world is amazing and
important and I really want to be here
year after year in order to to say that
to you and to get it out in the world
you know what he's doing in terms of
supporting people with HIV and AIDS and
there's a there's a whole request for
money tonight for a grant to go to
Puerto Rico night you know there are
we're not over it's not done the HIV is
still very common in our world yes
they're having a epidemic of pandemic in
Russia that's what I was gonna say I
know it's pie-in-the-sky because he does
such good work but you kind of wish that
he didn't have to have this party and
that this would be the last year that he
would have to have this party my darling
you're too young to remember this but we
said that in the eighties we kept saying
can we can it be no more can we not have
it
let him have an Oscar party for
something else or some other reason to
celebrate the end of AIDS in our
lifetime which is a commitment that he
has made and so maybe that will be the
thing that we will have one day and
hopefully so yeah sure semantics in
there be more transparent yes I hope so
yeah
yes we're looking at a fifth season and
we'll see when we're gonna shoot that so
we'll we'll see have you spoken to
Jeffery do you know how he's doing
I I have not spoken to him everybody's a
little shell-shocked yeah I would say
well let's hope because I love this show
and I would like to find a way for it to
continue because it's an important show
for television yes we we all would I
most most assuredly okay have a great
time tonight
[Music]